REINERT, A CNN MEDICAL ANALYST,
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AND
SURGERY AT GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY.
DR. REINERT, DOWN ON THE
NATIONAL MALL, SOME OF THESE
PROTESTERS WERE DISPLAYING
HOLOCAUST IMAGERY, COMPARING
VACCINE POLICY TO THE HOLOCAUST,
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY REPUGNANT.
ONE OF THE REACTIONS I HAD, DR.
REINERT, IS MANY OF THESE
PROTESTERS WERE STANDING VERY
CLOSE TO WHERE WE USED TO SEE
THOSE WHITE FLAGS, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF WHITE FLAGS MARKING
IN MEMORY ALL OF THOSE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WE LOST
IN THIS COUNTRY TO COVID.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING DOWN ON THE MALL
TODAY?
IT'S DISTURBING.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, TO SAY THE LEAST.
THE UNITED STATES LOST 10,000
PEOPLE LAST WEEK.
WE HAD 10,000 DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES LAST WEEK.
WE'VE LOST 860,000 PEOPLE,
THAT'S THREE TIMES THE NUMBER OF
COMBAT CASUALTY DEATHS IN WORLD
WAR II FOR THE UNITED STATES.
SO, YOU KNOW, TO SEE SO MANY
PEOPLE FIRST OF ALL DENYING THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS PANDEMIC, AND
THEN, YOU KNOW, TURNING THEIR
EYES ON SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW
WITH CLARITY WILL ALMOST
ELIMINATE YOUR RISK OF DYING IS
STARTLING.
AND RELATING TO SOMEHOW TO WHAT
6 MILLION JEWS WENT THROUGH WHO
WERE EXTERMINATED DURING THE
HOLOCAUST IS AT THE VERY LEAST
REPUGNANT.
I JUST FEEL THAT THIS COUNTRY
HAS IN MANY WAYS ASKED SO LITTLE
OF PEOPLE.
WE TREASURE FREEDOM SO MUCH.
ANY ASK FOR ANY CITIZEN IN THIS
COUNTRY APPEARS TO BE TOO MUCH.
SO WE'RE IN A PANDEMIC AND WE
MIRACULOUSLY DEVELOP A VACCINE
IN RECORD TIME THAT IS BETTER,
MORE EFFECTIVE THAN WE COULD
HAVE POSSIBLY HOPED.
AND A PROPORTION OF OUR COUNTRY,
25% OF ADULTS IN THIS COUNTRY,
SIMPLY REFUSE TO TAKE IT.
AND IT'S SOME SORT OF
IMPINGEMENT ON THEIR FREEDOM.
I NEVER WOULD HAVE GUESSED A
YEAR AGO THAT WE WOULD BE IN
THIS POSITION.
>> I KNOW YOU SAW BILL MAHER'S
PROGRAM, JOURNALIST BARRI WEISS
SAYS SHE'S DONE ON COVID.
>> I'M DONE WITH COVID.
I SPRAYED THE PRINGLES CANS THAT
I GOT FROM THE GROCERY STORE,
STRIPPED MY CLOTHES OFF BECAUSE
I THOUGHT COVID WOULD BE ON MY
CLOTHES.
I DID IT ALL.
THEN WE'RE TOLD YOU GET THE
VACCINE AND YOU GET BACK TO
NORMAL.
AND WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN BACK TO
AND IT'S RIDICULOUS AT THIS
POINT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE REMEMBERED
BY THE YOUNGER GENERATION AS A
CATASTROPHIC MORAL CRIME.
>> AND DR. REINERT, YOU TOLD
BARRI WEISS ESSENTIALLY SHE
NEEDED TO GROW UP.
>> SHE NEEDED TO GROW UP BECAUSE
SHE'S ACTING LIKE A CHILD.
WHEN YOU SAY YOU DON'T WANT TO
PLAY THAT GAME ANYMORE, YOU'LL
TAKE YOUR BALL AND GO HOME,
YOU'RE ACTING LIKE A CHILD.
I LIKE THE SACRIFICES SHE
ENUMERATED, SHE STRIPPED HER
CLOTHES WHEN SHE GOT HOME AND
SPRAYED THE GROCERY CANS.
MEANWHILE MY COLLEAGUES IN
HOSPITALS ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY
WENT IN TO CARE FOR PEOPLE DYING
FROM THE VIRUS AND CONTINUE TO
DO THAT EVERY DAY, MAN OUR ERs
AND ICUs EVERY DAY AND FOR THE
FIRST YEAR OF THIS PANDEMIC,
THEY DID THAT WITHOUT ANY
PROTECTION OF A VACCINE.
THAT'S THE SACRIFICE THEY MADE.
AND ALL THAT WE'VE DONE IS ASKED
THE PUBLIC TO WEAR A MASK WHEN
YOU GO OUT AND ABOUT, AND GET
VACCINATED.
SO I'M GLAD SHE'S DONE WITH IT.
BUT I SORT OF FEEL LIKE THIS
COUNTRY HAS BEEN IN A BOAT THAT
HAS FILLED WITH WATER AND SOME
OF US HAVE BEEN TRYING TO BAIL
OUT -- BAIL THE WATER OUT OF
THIS BOAT FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
BARRI WEISS BASICALLY SAYING I'M
DONE, I'M NOT BAILING THE WATER
OUT ANYMORE.
AND WHEN SOMEBODY WHO IS
RELATIVELY YOUNG AND RELATIVELY
HEALTHY SAYS THAT, WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING IS, I'LL BE OKAY IF I GET
THIS VIRUS, SCREW YOU, DOESN'T
MATTER TO ME WHAT HAPPENS TO
YOU.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE I GET FROM
HER.
>> YEAH, I'M DONE WITH THAT
ATTITUDE, HONESTLY.
SHE NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
TROLLING PEOPLE TO OWN THE LIBS
IS NOT A SACRIFICE.
FORMER FDA COMMERCIAL DR. SCOTT
GOTTLIEB SAID LATE MARCH IS
PROBABLY THE SOONEST A COVID
VACCINE FOR KIDS UNDER 5 COULD
BE AVAILABLE.
HOW DOES THAT TIME FRAME SOUND
TO YOU?
AND WHAT'S THE MESSAGE TO
PARENTS OF YOUNG CHILDREN WHO
WANT TO GET THEIR YOUNG KIDS
VACCINATED AND PROTECTED?
>> I THINK THE END OF MARCH
WOULD BE GREAT.
MY MESSAGE TO PARENTS WITH
LITTLE KIDS IS HANG IN THERE.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
YOU'RE TRYING TO WALK THE LINE
BETWEEN TRYING TO HAVE SOME
NORMALCY IN YOUR FAMILY BUT
PROTECT YOUR KIDS FROM GETTING
SICK.
I UNDERSTAND IT.
WE HAVE TO HANG IN THERE FOR
JUST ANOTHER COUPLE OF MONTHS.
AGAIN, THIS IS EASIER TO DO WHEN
WE'RE ALL SINGING FR